[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANIA ANZULEWICZ:
Harimata is a company
which aims to develop a
system for early detection
of disorders in children.
KRZYSIEK SOBOTA:
We're gathering a lot
of raw data from the tablets,
like touch data, data
from sensors like
accelerometer gyroscope.
And when you're gathering
it in the NoSQL database,
then this raw data
is preprocessed
in a cloud service.
And we then write results
to the SQL database.
ANIA ANZULEWICZ: Typically, the
diagnosis of autism spectrum
disorders takes several months.
And many of the
children are diagnosed
too late when the time
window for early intervention
is already closed.
With our technology, we
can identify the signs
of autism even in two-year-olds.
So we have this
two-year advantage.
Right?
It gives time for
early intervention,
which allows many
of these children
for independent
life in the future.